(rhythmic electric music)
- [Voiceover] When you see
the players get the ball
in their hand for the first
time it's a cross between
intrigue and excitement.
It's great to see 'em try and
bounce the ball and to see it
actually bounce away.
It can make the best of people
look really, really silly.
(wild cheering)
- [Voiceover] The #1 sport in Australia
is Australian Rules Football.
It's basically a cross
between rugby and soccer.
And the fans go crazy for it.
There's one problem.
They don't have enough tall people.
So what do they do?
They come to the States.
- This combines the US AFL
Combine and we started this
four years ago.
Basically in a search for
guys six-foot-seven and above.
- [Voiceover] And these
tall American athletes,
they don't really need to
know a lot about Australia.
- It's a home of the kangaroos, I think.
- I know it's a lotta kangaroos.
- I hear a lot about kangaroos
and spiders and snakes.
- [Michael] In selecting these
athletes we predominantly
look for guys that are hungry.
Most of the participants
predominantly come from basketball.
The concept of basketball in
terms of the athlete being
in traffic and having spatial
awareness and those sorts
of things is really
transferable to our game.
- [Voiceover] Which is good
news because less than two percent
of college basketball players
will make it to the pros.
The Australian Football League
gives them another chance
to live out their dreams
of being a pro athlete.
- [Michael] Most of the
participants are quite shocked
when they see the game for the first time.
- [Voiceover] The question
is, what do the athletes
think of all this?
- When I got to come on invite I thought
it was fake, actually.
I thought it was a scam.
- First thing I thought,
- I thought they was contacting
the wrong person, actually.
- What is Australian Football?
- [Voiceover] Skepticism aside,
how do you teach these guys
a game they never even heard of before?
- [Michael] So the Combine
kicks off in the early piece
with a physical testing,
and then start to building
to the skills, the basics
of hand-balling, the ability
to see what they're like with their hands.
Then we can start to get into
the more competitive stuff
where they might crash and
bash into each other which,
they love that.
(roaring crowd)
- [Voiceover] This is Mason Cox.
He played basketball at Oklahoma State.
Two years ago, he was just
like one of these guys
on the Combine.
Now, he's playing
professionally in Australia.
- [Michael] They can be
one of the 22 superstars
out there on an AFL team.
It's a fantastic opportunity
for these guys to continue
their professional career.